look upon each other you say the words I
would say the challenge with this
sequence was finding a way to present
information that at least a good portion
of the audience already had in a way
that was dramatic and exciting the High
Septon but regularly honor in a secret
ceremony there's always meant to be a
montage easily something you can see the
important thing was getting Sam and
brand together because they had varying
pieces of the puzzle but they didn't
have all the pieces and cisely say that
actually these were two people in love
and that this whole thing that started
off the series Game of Thrones Robert's
rebellion was a total lie
John is not just the son of Rhaegar and
Lyanna but he's the true born son he's
not a bastard and that means he's the
rightful heir to the Iron Throne that
changes everything man it's great to
shoot something it's a revelatory moment
and then of course the even bigger a
revelatory moment I think they both know
it's wrong I think they both know it's
gonna cause problems but it's that thing
when you suddenly feel that deeply about
someone it's like a runaway train you
can't stop it happening
you don't even get the relief of how
beautiful it could be or should be it's
not good but it should be but it's not
and if she's his aunt so there's that if
that kind of thing would bother you
might be the reaction I like looking at
and going oh god I'm sorry let's let's
go cat but the fact he is actually heir
to the throne
I can lord that over Amelia every day
every day we tried to contrast the
various season endings so that they
don't feel too similar so last season we
had a pretty [ __ ] and ending with them
Danny finally sailing west towards
Westeros you're supposed to feel like
you know Sparky ending and this one's
like oh and [ __ ] nose as a season
closer it's phenomenal and from a
directing point of view okay how do we
do that every year Dan and David have
cooked up something that makes us read
the outline and the script and just go
oh [ __ ] how the hell are we gonna do
this
and what really kind of got me super
jazzed I guess was only saw the first
conceptual paintings they're not
specific to shots or whatever they're
just like this is the vibe of the scene
and so they'll do this like beautiful
painting of the of a dragon you know
blowing blue flame blowing a hole in the
wall you're like now I see a holy crow
like that is spectacular and a lot of it
is virtual there are only so many pieces
you can physically shoot of course
whatever we can shoot we did shoot we
have fire elements that were shot that
blast against the wall whites on
green-screen we have the night King on a
motion base on the back of zombie
viscera on the ice dragon we looked back
at the models that we created when
Tyrion visited the two sick dragons the
ribs are poking through the skin and
their skin has become translucent we
added the wound which is very important
the spear wound that kills him we also
worked on what does his fire look like
because it's not healthy fire it's you
know it's a magical evil fire this
sequence is a real proof of just
dedication and commitment of that whole
team of people working around the world
to make something that's impossible and
unreal seem so real and so present
I didn't see that coming
now let go oh it's gonna be fun winter
is here and it's all hitting the fan
from all directions yeah we've talked a
long time about seeing the wall come
down it's all getting real it's suddenly
look terrifying they're breaching the
wall you know it's incest happening and
it's amazing saying is never
hey everybody's special Game of Thrones
episode so let's break it down they do a
good job of explaining some of the more
contentious story points in what they
intended a lot of you have asked me
about the conspiracy theories
surrounding the beginning of Robert's
rebellion in whether or not Robert found
out about the lie and didn't tell
anybody but they also clarify some of
the mythology behind vissarion's so just
a couple really big questions answered
and if you didn't know there's a brand
new game of Thrones book that was just
published this week it's a short story
about the sons of Aegon the conquerer it
even mentions one of Samwell Tarly --zz
ancestors called Samwell the Savage so
that book is what the giveaway is going
to be for this week all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video obviously we're
doing videos till season 8 gets here but
starting with a Rhaegar Liana stuff so
there weren't as many big questions
about the what the why was the bigger
thing here and I love the way that they
say most of the audience understood but
they still had to explain it in a visual
way they said they had that problem all
the way back in season 1 so this has
always been a thing for Game of Thrones
is that they have to find a way for the
show to convey information even if it's
common knowledge so R plus L equals J
has been a thing since the first book
came out people wondered after Ned Stark
had his dreams was he dreaming about
Liana having a baby
maybe that baby is Jon Snow Martin was
probably always going to reveal that
information in winds of winter the
problem is is that even if he did in
that book had been published years ago
before we got to season 6 the show still
has to do a version of that so if you're
wondering why the show doesn't do more
scenes like this it's just because
they're not absolutely relevant for big
information reveals the only reason the
show did this now is because they wanted
to create drama between Jon Snow and
Daenerys like create some cracks in the
Alliance create a reason for them not to
be together so if you're wondering why
we haven't seen the Trident or other big
Robert's rebellion flashbacks it's just
because those scenes aren't necessary
for what's happening in present day so
anytime there's some contextual moment
that they need and it's a really big
book moment that's what they tend to go
for but as for future flashbacks just
because the previous trend the last
couple of seasons has been Jon Snow's
specific flashbacks I think that will
continue to be the case so if we get
season eight Trident flashbacks or
something
else I think they'll also continue to be
about John snow but I feel like for the
most part they've answered all the
questions they need to about his origins
he's the true born son of Rhaegar Liana
he has a stronger claim to the throne
than Daenerys now like kid Harrington
makes that joke I can lure divert Emilia
every day every day
moving into undead ice dragon territory
this actually confirms some of the
things that I previously thought like my
initial take after the episode aired
people were wondering why blue fire why
does Viserion work this way given what
happened to him before the whole
explainer is that it is the night Kings
magic he's breathing magical fire he's
flying by magic whether you think it
works it doesn't work that's what they
were going for I think the idea now is
is is he more powerful than the other
dragons because drogon is still the
largest I know it's kind of hard to tell
because they're all so large now but
drogon is still proportionately larger
than Viserion and regal but i think i
added it to a previous video Neil
deGrasse Tyson was going all science on
the episode where he said that the blue
fire was basically three times hotter
than regular fire so even if you're not
thinking about anything else with the
night Kings magic that by itself would
make Viserion more powerful than the
other dragons so the night King has had
a thousand years to perfect his magic he
gets his hands on a dragon he probably
knows more about the Dragons than
Daenerys does and the other big thing
they don't quite clarify it here but the
idea of whether or not vissarion's blue
fire can actually hurt Daenerys the
dragons are capable of killing each
other so I think that Daenerys is only
resistant to vissarion's blue fire but
if she were took bathe and that one her
clothes would all be incinerated so
she'd be naked after that all of her
hair would be singed off and she might
get some third-degree burns but she
could probably soak a little bit of
damage and that just going on the TV
shows logic
Daenerys in the books is a little bit
different the way the blood magic
protects her against the fire but a lot
of the way any of those battles go will
depend on who's there to help them out
because I don't think they're gonna do
any of that by themselves but the whole
deal with that new short story that
George our Martin just published is that
it's a sequel to the princess and the
Queen and the rogue Prince dealing with
Targaryen Kings after Aegon the
conquerer so the new ones
deals with his two sons is actually
pretty cool so I'll probably do a video
on in the next couple days and read a
little bit from it it's only about 26
pages long but it's always fun to read
those stories and see how Martin invokes
a lot of the stuff that's happening in
present day like there are a lot of
themes that recur there are a lot of
people that have the same names like Sam
wells ancestor Samwell of the Savage so
I know I also said I do a casting video
for season 8 there are a couple minor
roles that they're casting so that'll
come in the next couple days - but
tonight at midnight they're dropping a
trailer for the New Mutants movie Maisie
Williams is actually in that she's
playing Wolfsbane so the wolf from Game
of Thrones is playing a wolf in a Marvel
movie so that won't be till midnight
tonight though congratulations to Derek
for real please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here to learn
all about the season 8 episode schedule
and you can click here for that
Targaryen prequel trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you